here at morning west farms we love our
turkeys
and this thanksgiving there's no length
we won't go to to ensure the highest
quality turkey gets from our farm to
your table our turkeys are raised on an
entirely organic diet of pesticide free
whole grains and seeds and as always
they're completely hormone free
and larry
the turkeys
our birds are never caged they roam free
on large plots of unfenced land where
they get plenty of exercise fresh air
and relaxation
and larry for real
those turkeys
and every morning as the warm dakota sun
rises the gentle warble of our birds can
be heard as they happily mill about in
tall fields of wheat as the golden light
reflects off their salubrious plumage
oh and have i mentioned that larry
the turkeys
hi i'm charles morning owner of morning
west farms
i know our methods might be slightly
different than those of our competitors
but i personally guarantee there's no
better way to ensure a premium bird how
do i know
i used to be the larry
morning west farms
we love turkey
you